قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو ان حكومته قررت اليوم اقامه
مستوطنه جديده في غلاف غزه مضيفا ان اقامه
المستوطنه دليل اخر على قوه غلاف غزه وقوه
اسرائيل حسب تعبيره وقال انه يفخر بتعزيز
الاستيطان في جميع انحاء البلاد واكدان
نتنياهو ان الامر الاكثر اهميه للرد على
ما سماه الارهاب هو تعزيز الاستيطان وهو
ما تقوم به حكومه نتنياهو حسب تعبيره
واعرب عن فخر حكومته ببناء ما سماها ارض
اسرائيل وبتعزيز الاستيطان في جميع انحاء
البلاد على حد قوله
تنضم الينا من القدس مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري نجوان اين ستقام هذه المستوطنه
الجديده والتفاصيل المتعلقه بها
نعم بحسب المعلومات الاوليه فان هذه
المستوطنه او البلده الاسرائيليه فيما
يعرف بمنطقه غلاف غزه ستقام في القطاع
الشرقي من الحدود مع غزه فيما يعرف
بالمجلس الاقليمي ازدوتها بالقرب من
مستوطنه اخرى يطلق عليها اسم سعد وهي ستضم
ما يقارب 500 وحده استيطانيه ل 500 عائله
اسرائيليه ضمن ما تعرفه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تشجيع الاستيطان والبناء في
مناطق النقب وفي منطقه غلاف غزه بعد كل
عمليه فلسطينيه عاده تقابل من قبل
الحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه بالاعلان
عن بناء استيطاني جديد او توسيع لمستوطنات
قائمه علما ان الحكومات الاسرائيليه لا
تنتظر اي ذريعه
لكي تقوم بال الاستيطان والتوسع
الاستيطاني في اي منطقه سواء كان في الضفه
الغربيه او في مناطق الجليل او النقب هذا
الاعلان ربطه اليوم نتنياهو وفقا لحديثه
في مستهل الجلسه الاسبوعيه للحكومه بانه
سيقابل ما وصفه عمليات الارهاب بمعنى ان
ذلك ياتي بعد العمليات الفلسطينيه المسلحه
التي شهدتها مدينه القدس لكن من جهه اخرى
هذا يترافق فدا مع مشاريع استيطانيه اخرى
تنوي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المصادقه عليها هذا ما نشر قبل فتره وجيزه
في احدى الصحف الاسرائيليه ان هناك خطه
استيطانيه كبيره جدا بصدد ان تصادق عليها
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ما لا يقل عن
18000 وحده استيطانيه في مناطق مختلفه في
الضفه الغربيه
سيتم بناؤها سواء كان في مست قائمه او
تشريع لبؤر استيطانيه تعرف بالبؤر
الاستيطانيه غير الشرعيه وفق القانون
الاسرائيلي وهي بؤر اقامها مستوطنون دون
موافقه من الحكومه الاسرائيليه وهذا كان
ايضا ضمن نص الاتفاق الائتلاف بين بنيامين
نتنياهو وبين احزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه
تحديدا مع حزب وزير الامن القومي اتمار
بني كبير بان يتم
شرعنه بؤر استيطانيه عشرات البؤر ملا يقل
عن 60 بؤره اقامها مستوطنون دون تصديق
الحكومات الاسرائيليه هذا من جهه من جهه
اخرى هناك ايضا مشروع لتوسيع مستوطنه تعرف
بنفسيون مقامه على اراضي بلده جبل المكبر
في القدس المحتله وتم تاجيل جلسه للتصديق
على هذا
المخطط ايضا الى ما بعد زياره بلينكن كان
من المفترض ان تجتمع اللجنه اللوائيه على
تخطيط وبناء المستوطنات في فتره زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بلينكن الاسبوع
الماضي وتم تاجيل هذه الجلسه الى ما بعد
انتهاء زيارته ولكن ايضا كان اليوم نواب
من الائتلاف الحكومي في منطقه
قلنديا ما يعرف بالمخطط الاستيطاني على
مطار قلنديا الفاصل بين مدينه رام الله
والقدس لاحياء مخطط اخر كانت الحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه ايضا تؤجله بسبب
ضغط من قبل الاداره الامريكيه وضغط من
الاتحاد الاوروبي لانه سيعزل القدس كليا
من الجهه الشماليه عن منطقه رام الله
الغربيه
واليوم هناك محاولات ايضا لاحياء هذا
المشروع الذي بموجبه سيتم اقامه الاف
الوحدات الاستيطانيه كحزام استيطاني من
الجهه الشماليه للقدس المحتله
من القدس